uh sadly dr deborah burks now retired
became an unfortunate node of
disinformation during her work
for the trump administration on the
coronavirus pandemic and you might
remember the clips of dr burke's
repeating how smart and thoughtful
donald trump is she would repeat
falsehoods about the reality of the
virus
she would make obviously false claims
about how well things are going here
or there thanks to donald trump and many
of us did not fall forward although some
did
now dr burks has retired and she did an
interesting interview yesterday with
cbs's face the nation and she sort of
came clean about the trump
administration's handling of coronavirus
and we're going to look at some [ __ ]
clips
not crips we're going to look at clips
and this is
all fine and good i mean she's telling
us things we all suspected
but it's too damn late the time to sound
the alarm would have been 10 months ago
when clearly she knew donald trump was
in over his head and this was being
mishandled
coming clean when trump's gone and
you're retired
and we have two soon-to-be three or even
four vaccines
it's too late now it's still interesting
in a car crash sort of way to hear what
she has to say
asked if donald trump was merely
distracted from the virus which is
deadly enough
dr burke says there were actually people
in the white house
who actively thought the coronavirus
pandemic was a hoax
were there coveted deniers in the white
house
there are people in the white house and
i think people around this country
because i've had the privilege to meet
them
and listen to them and hear them because
i wanted to hear what people were saying
there were people who definitely
believed that this was a hoax
why i think because the information was
confusing
at the beginning i think because we
didn't talk about the spectrum of
disease
because everyone interpreted on what
they knew
and so they saw people get coveted and
be fine now she almost blames herself
there we didn't talk about the spectrum
of the of disease
as if that would have changed the minds
of the people telling trump not to worry
about this
these were people committed for
political reasons to claiming or
believing that it was a hoax
and it's horrifying she presenting other
data
was not going to make a difference and
dr burks in this next clip claims
that despite the fact that she was the
coordinator of the white house coveted
task force
she basically never saw trump in the
spring or
you gave an interview what we're seeing
today is different from march and april
it is extraordinarily widespread and
then president trump
tweeted he blasted you for saying that
did you ever speak to him
after that i hadn't seen him for months
before that or months after that
um but that was like that was the
coordinator of the coveted
that was an extraordinary moment because
i also
got yelled at by um
the speaker who i have tremendous i mean
obviously women have
gone through a lot to get in their
positions i have tremendous respect
for women and women leadership speaker
pelosi said she didn't have confidence
in you
because you were working for president
trump so i don't have confidence
and anyone who stands there while the
president says uh
swallow lysol is going to cure your
virus you know he'll kill you and you
won't have the virus anymore
and so that was very hard because i've
known her from the hiv world so again
the big news
berks hadn't seen trump in person for
months before that
nor after that covet coordinator
not seeing the president of the united
states trump simply didn't care
which we knew she's just confirming it
uh berks asked
how the hell did trump get coveted
arguably the person who could be
the most protected they were supposedly
testing everybody every day
and dr burke says nobody at the white
house wore a mask take a listen to this
but how did the task force allow the
president who calls himself a germaphobe
to get covet himself how did that happen
there were only two people who regularly
wore a mask in the white house
myself and tyler ann mcguffrey the
support person that i had from hhs
so the staff around the president was
not wearing a mask
he's the commander-in-chief this is a
national security risk
how is that possible i think people
believed
wrongly that testing
testing would be adequate how is that
possible i think they believe that
testing is a surrogate for a public
health
intervention but did you say the
president united states needs to wear a
mask
did you press mike pence on that did you
press mark meadows as chief of staff
there are multiple communications about
masking yeah
um this tells you a lot and and again
we suspected this stuff but to hear her
say it
is both again too little too late but
stunning to hear that this degree of
incompetence surrounded trump
here she explains that someone was
giving trump graphs that weren't coming
from her
she doesn't know who it was but somebody
was giving trump other data but
and by data i mean pictures essentially
do you think president trump appreciated
the gravity of the health crisis you
were describing
i think the president appreciated the
gravity in march
it took a while after i arrived in the
white house
to remove all of the answer larry data
that was coming in
i mean there was parallel data streams
coming into the white house that were
not transparently utilized
and i needed to stop that where you mean
outside advisors
outside advisors coming to inside
advisors
and to this day i mean until the day i
left i am
i'm convinced there were parallel data
streams because i disinformation
i saw the president presenting graphs
that i never made
so i know that someone or someone out
there or someone inside was creating a
parallel set of data and graphics that
were shown to the president
i don't know to this day who parallel
data
and strange graphs and charts huh
not unique to the pandemic
within the trump administration i think
we all remember the hurricane sharpie
incident and other
instances of bogus data and graphs so
all of our suspicions were true and
that's why this happened
early trump didn't take it seriously
after
april he also didn't and no one at the
white house
did that was in his immediate inner
circle the people taking it seriously
like dr burks to some degree although
she did play
a role in in perpetuating disinformation
dr fauci
they weren't even talking to donald
trump for months at a time and there
were people
at the white house who believed it was a
hoax
this is the full story and it explains
everything that went on perfectly
clearly they
disbanded the pandemic response team
they threw out
or ignored the pandemic response
playbook left behind
color-coded by the obama administration
they weren't wearing masks at the white
house they weren't talking to dr burke's
trump wasn't and burke's coming clean
now is great for the record
but it didn't help at all back then the
if
is there a silver lining here there is
knowing the degree of uh
of disregard that the trump
administration had for the virus
and seeing how joe biden is actually
taking this issue head-on from day one
suggests
to me as if we didn't know from all of
the examples from new zealand and rwanda
and taiwan and others
that having a federal administration
focus focused on this will make a really
big difference like things got
disastrously bad in the us
and they got that bad with total
incompetence and disregard from the
trump administration
uh now that we have people paying
attention to it i am even more confident
that it will make a huge difference
could dr berks and dr fauci and someone
else maybe have come together
in may and publicly denounced everything
that was going on
yeah maybe i don't know and and again
the question that i have is
i don't know what happens if they do if
they all get fired and get replaced with
total sycophants berks kind of became a
sycophant by by exclude by by default
fauci did not but he was pushed out to a
great degree
i don't know if they all come together
and say this has to stop this is what's
going on they may all get fired and and
get replaced by the equivalent of
uh dr scott atlas in all of these
positions but nothing surprising
whatsoever
in what dr deborah burks tells us would
have been nice for her to say it a
little bit sooner for sure
we'll have more coverage of this on our
instagram page you can find us on
instagram at david pakman
and you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman
i posted some interesting things over
the weekend that you may find
enjoyable or horrifying depending on
your
predisposition quick break back after
this